المركز ضبط الامني في الشميسي معنى مراسل
العربيه السلطان السلمي سلطان مرحبا بك
كيف يتم العمل الان على تنفيذ هذا القرار
اهلا بكافه مشاهدي قناه العربيه بالفعل من
امام مركز الضبط الامني بالشميسي وهو يعد
من اكبر المنافذ المؤديه الى العاصمه
المقدسه نتحدث عن سبعه مراكز او سبعه
مراكز ضبط امني على كافه منافذ مكه التي
تؤدي للدخول الى العاصمه المقدسه قامت امن
الطرق السعوديه
بنشر تعليمات واضحه ودقيقه فيما يتعلق
بمنع دخول كافه المقيمين الى العاصمه
المقدسه لثلاث حالات فقط وهي لمن يملك
تصريح عمره
عفوا او تصريح حج او هويه مقيم صادره من
العاصمه المقدسه هذا القرار بدا يوم امس
الاثنين تحديدا لخوم الخامس والعشرين من
شهر 10 لهذا العام وسوف يستمر حتى انتهاء
موسم حجر هذا العام وياتي هذه القرارات في
كل عام في مثل هذا التوقيت للحد من وجود
حجاج مخالفين داخل العاصمه المقدسه نتحدث
فيما يتعلق بالمواطنين السعوديين حتى
المواطن السعودي لا يستطيع الدخول الى مكه
المكرمه
في حال كان في حال كان لابس لبس الاحرام
او معتمر الا بتطبيق نسك فقط فيما يتعلق
بالمقيمين الساكنين والقاتنين في مكه
المكرمه يستطيعون الدخول والخروج من مكه
بشكل سلس بشرط ان يكون حامل هويه هويه
مقيم الصادره من العاصمه المقدس فيما
يتعلق بالمقيمين الرقادمين من جده
والراغبين بالدخول الى العاصمه المقدسه
لاداء العمره يشترط ان يكون هنالك تصريح
من تطبيق بدات امن الطرق بعد عملها
والتاكد من كافه الهويات والتصاريح
المتعلقه بهؤلاء المقيمين كما نشاهد
امامكم يقوم رجل الامن باخذ الهويات
والتاكد من التصاريح والهويات فيما يتعلق
بذلك في حال وجود مخالفين يتم اخذ بيانات
السائق والافراد الذين هم من هم على او من
هم في متن السوا على مجلس او داخل السياره
من ثم يتم اعادتهم بشكل طبيعي الى مدينه
جده حتى يمكننا تصريح لهم للعمره او تصريح
اقامه بمدينه بمكه المكرمه او حتى هويه
خاصه او تصريع عمل داخل المشاعر المقدسه
كل هذه الانظمه تجري تجري الان في كافه
المنافذ السبعه الرئيسيه من ضمنها الشميسي
وكذلك منفذ النواريه والكعكيه وغيرها من
منافذ داخل العاصمه المقدسه ايضا هناك
تجديد كبير من قبل هؤلاء الرجال للتاكد من
كافه الهويات وسلامتها فيما يتعلق
بالحافلات الضخمه هنالك مسارات مخصصه لهم
ايضا وجود مراء كاميرات مراقبه امنيه
للرسل ايضا وجود نقاط فرز متعدده هذه
النقطه الاولى ايضا هنالك نقاط اخرى في في
المقدمه للتاكد من كافه اوراق الثبوتيه
الخاصه بهؤلاء المقيمين كما نشاهد الان
يتم تحويل هذه السيارات الى مسارات اخرى
ومن ثم يتم ارجاعهم في حال وجود او عدم
وجود تصريح او هويه مقيم صادره من مكه
المكرمه شكرا لك سلطان السلمي من مركز
الضبط الامني في الشميسي
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات